some good news to share with you a brand
new french restaurant opened up in the
southwest part of town today that's
right it's called the cafe
we've followed the owners on their
journey since they opened up their first
bakery at lake las vegas they're second
in henderson and now they're third in
southern highlands
the southern highlands community has
been hungry for something like this it's
unbelievable i mean we knew that
we offer a great product and we built a
beautiful space we didn't know how the
the community will react where we
couldn't be more excited
the community supports the couple's
endeavors owners carmen barber and david
gazzano have worked in luxury service
based industries like dining and retail
for decades carmen's from romania david
from france
they opened look cafe du lac in lake las
vegas in the summer of 2017.
their second restaurant in the heart of
green valley la cafe duval at the
beginning of the pandemic and now the
third location what's the secret to
opening not one but two during a
challenging time the couple says
excellent service along with the highest
quality level of food crabs and garlic
definitely garlics are savory crepes
we specialize to that
and we also have some sarah some paninis
and and all the beautiful french
bakeries behind me and their house
specials are what really draw the crowds
in foie gras and escargot and riyadh
and that's going to be a big hit we've
already had people have escargot for
breakfast